[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joining you from the interval here
in san francisco where i'll be joined
by adam rogers our speaker tonight who
is going to be speaking about the
history and future
of color and perception and culture adam
rogers
was one of the very first speakers we
had here at the interval way back in
2014 on his last book proof which was
really a kind of a similar study
but on alcohol and culture but tonight
he's going to be talking about
both the science and history of color
and perception and how it has affected
civilization through
time welcome adam rogers
thank you xander it's really it's good
to be back uh
i want you to picture in your mind the
quintessential yellow
so not an object not a yellow thing
not a lemon but just yellow not orangey
not greenish yellow
okay you got it
now i don't know if this is it for you
this is how a lot of computers
code like yellow yellow and of course
it'll look different on every screen
because nobody calibrates the colors of
their screens and all screens are
different
all things being equal though and this
is a little bit weird
the yellow that you would pick as
perfect as quintessential if somebody
shined a light and gave you the controls
of the dials to pick a perfect yellow is
probably very very close
to what another person would pick of
course all things are never equal we
measure color in a lot of ways
saturation brightness intensity
and those metrics vary from place to
place in time to time when we talk about
color let's try another warm-up now i
want you to picture your perfect green
so not bluish not yellowish green
okay you got it now here's a weird thing
the green in your head right now is
almost certainly not
the green that someone else would think
of or would pick as their quintessential
green
people vary by a lot if you shine do
that thing where you shine the light in
their face and let them control the
dials
it'll vary by as much as 60 nanometers
if describing colors
by their wavelength is your thing this
is a good green
it's fine um it's a little yellow for me
actually
but an important question to ask here i
think is why would this green not be
your perfect quintessential green
because the blue green region of what
scientists call a color space
the entire multi-dimensional range of
colors
and variations in colors possible and
perceivable is a brutal
place it is a weirdish wild space now
partially
this is because of how your eyes and
brains work partially it's a function of
your personal experience of philosophy
of language of all the green lights
you've ever seen every traffic signal
every green field of england every
blade of grass every incredible hulk
color is physics color is culture and
you probably remember something
from elementary school called primary
colors the idea of those is that you
could have specific colors or
really and we'll talk more about this
too specific names
for colors that we agree upon and then
somehow try to understand
how those colors mix and come together
to form all the other colors because of
course color
is a continuous sort of curve or wave
form i guess
there's red yellow blue those are the
primary colors i was taught there's red
green blue those are the primary colors
your computer was taught
there's the mancell primary colors which
is a system of organizing color
this sort of unifies them all for
comparison's sake you can see how
different they are around the outside
is what isaac newton called the spectrum
the middle ring or the artist's
primaries
and secondaries in the inner ring are
the additive colors
red green blue shine light put those
together they mix and form other colors
and the subtractive or reflective colors
that you'd find in a pigment cyan
magenta yellow and
black cmyk history is littered
with the rubble of attempts to put
colors into some kind of order
to make them behave so that printers and
painters and dyers and weavers
and digital animators and artists of all
sorts
and people every day can use them can
take this mysterious but ubiquitous
feature of the universe
and turn it into something that we
change that we transform and transforms
us
into a technology so here's the
hypothesis
when we talk about color we are actually
talking about three separate but related
and overlapping things
so first is color that happens without
us the tree falls in the forest it's
green even if we're not there
to see it tumble that's physics
chemistry the oscillation of
electromagnetic fields moving in a
direction
electromagnetic energy streaming from
the sun hitting earth's atmosphere
interacting hitting other surfaces and
particles
light 1.21 sextillion photons
hitting every square meter of earth's
sunlit surface every second
color is something that we make colored
things by dent of our hands and our
effort and our cognitive abilities
roman purple egyptian blue move colors
that didn't
exist on earth or anywhere in the
universe i mean you know
maybe until human ingenuity makes use of
all that physics and chemistry to make
them happen
usually we call these things pigments
these are things that absorb some colors
of light and reflect others presenting a
color to our eyes
the image that you see there are jugs
full of quantum dots eventually those
are going to be part of led tvs
it's arguably one of the most advanced
way people make colors today
and third there's the color that our
eyes and brains manufacture from those
other two things
light all around us bounces off or
through or among
surfaces into our eyeballs where
hideously complicated biological sensors
transduce
photons into neuroelectrical signals
the image that you see now is uh ramona
kahal's hand-drawn map of a mammal's
retina
that comb-looking part up at the top are
the rods and cones
those are the photoreceptors the back of
the retina that
perceive light and color this is isaac
newton's original
spectrum um with colors added later he
didn't draw the colors in when he did it
famously in 1665 he goes on the run from
the plague and hides out at his mother's
house
closes up the shutters with the study
he's working in pokes a hole in the wall
sunlight comes in he
lets that sunlight go through a then
relatively new optical technology called
the prism
and sees on the opposite wall color is
splayed out in a line
the eyes in the brain don't perceive the
same world of color that the universe
creates
what we think of as color is like all
the other senses
just an approximation so that first way
of looking at things this is
going to be familiar to you this is the
electromagnetic spectrum colored light
is in one sense just the teensiest part
of the physics that surround them and
this sort of makes sense why it's that
narrow band because we're using
meat sensors to perceive it longer
wavelengths would cook those meat
sensors
and shorter wavelengths would ionize
them into little balls of cancer
we humans call anything between about
380 nanometers and about 750 nanometers
we call that stretch visible light those
are colors
to us you can see here that the peak
spectra of the three of them that most
human beings have in their eyes
people call those red green and blue or
short medium and long wavelengths but
you can see that the peaks aren't well
distributed
the tails overlap this is like
everything else in our meat suits an
evolutionary cluj
and in some humans one or two of them
doesn't work
some rare humans have a whole other one
of them in there in between the green
and the blue
they are tetrachromats as opposed to
most of us
trichromats but the wavelengths it
responds to still fall inside the range
of what we
tend to call visible but look at this
birds birds are tetrachromats they see
colors way down into the ultraviolet
and bees they're trichomatic like us but
they don't even bother with red
they're seeing the green and the blue
and then ultraviolet the natural world
positively glows to these other animals
we can't even begin to imagine and we
can begin to imagine but we don't see
what they see they have other
colors and look at this show off this is
a mana shrimp 12 photoreceptors
into the uv and near infrared jerks i
mean now except for the colors out on
the edges
uh most scientists don't actually think
that the manta shrimp
sees more colors than humans it might
not discriminate among a zillion where
we only do a kajillion or something like
that
it does do it faster the connections
between those receptors and and what
what passes for a brain in a mantis
shrimp i'm not trying to be offensive
but you know
mantis shrimp but the point that i'm
trying to make here is that color is
quite literally in the eye of the
beholder what colors we see depend on
our
our biology the cones sensitive to long
middle and short wavelengths all do
something called quantum catch they're
kind of adding up the number of photons
they're receiving at the energy levels
that they're sensitive to
this is a function of the proton
structures around them responding to
that energy
they aren't just sending red green and
blue signals back into the brain they're
combining their signals with each other
and with other kinds of neural
all kinds of neurons adjacent to them
and other kinds of cells that are
helping that process doing complicated
calculations within the eye
they're also doing overall number of
photons to calculate brightness or
intensity because the amount of light
and dark is part of the way we perceive
color and then that all reaches back you
can see in this diagram those two
circles at the top there are our
eyeballs everything else is brain
and once you get into the brain what you
would love to say is like oh well
there's like a part for red and a part
for blue and a part for
green but no it's not like that at all
the parts of the visual cortex may or
may not map to specific colors
perceptions of colors the neuroscience
community's been arguing about this for
decades
we don't even really know completely
why we or anything else sees color at
all
clearly it's some kind of information
clearly it's evolutionary evolutionarily
useful
part of the answer might be here if
you're local to long now you might
recognize the salt ponds
at the southern edge of the san
francisco bay those colors
come at least in large part from salt
loving extremophile microbes
called halobacteria paleobacteria aren't
bacteria at all
uh they are members of the kingdom
archaea the oldest life on earth three
or four billion years old
obviously they do not see they don't
have eyes they are six microns long
they have color which means they have
pigments lots in fact
and they also know how to avoid blue
light and swim toward orange
which is weird because again no eyes so
halo bacteria have a
protein called bacteriorhodopsin they're
using it
not to perceive light but as a proton
pump
basically they turn light into energy
but the thing is
that while the overall structure of the
protein is pretty close to ours
the individual amino acids that make up
that protein are different
it's like making the same spaceship with
different legos
so no one knows for sure if our color
vision
evolved from their color vision or if
color vision is so evolutionarily
valuable that that evolution just comes
up with it
again and again and over time the same
approach with different structures
nobody knows it's good for something and
we humans
keep making our own colors to feed our
appetite for it this is uh blombos cave
it's on the coast of south africa it's
been the location of a bunch of really
exciting archaeological finds over the
years
some of the first ornamental beads one
of the first drawings the human beings
ever made
between 10 and 20 meters down about 100
000 years old
the archaeologists who worked that cave
found something remarkable
these are abalone shells and the one on
the right you can see a little rock
down at the bottom and it's sort of
molded to the shape of the inner surface
than the nacreous substance on the
inside of the shell and you'll see also
some reddish color there that's ochre
and iron oxide these are tools for
grinding that ochre down
for mixing it with they found samples of
what's called trabecular bone like you'd
find in the spine it's sort of
fat and narrow and cartilage porous and
gooey these are tools to mix all that
together and make
a pigment to turn ochre into a paint
it's the oldest known example
of human beings taking a natural
material and turning into colored stuff
they can use
the archeologists who found them led by
a researcher named christopher
henschelwood
called these tool kits blombos was a
workshop
for making color technology but by the
time you have people painting
for example the insides of the caves at
lisco in the south of france tens of
thousands of years after
what was going on blombos you have a
pretty wide palette now this isn't
obviously enough of a gamut
to depict the entire natural world but
there's a lot of color there you've got
the ochres there's some coppery stuff
for green
the blacks are magnesium and carbon like
soot that's easy because you've got
fires
and sometimes you'll have something
almost always calcium carbonate based
for white and it's enough to make some
really striking image like these these
are from
the simulated lisco cave that the french
built just outside the real cave but you
can also ask
could the people who painted it also
have had other pigments
and the answer is yes maybe they had a
blue made from flowers or something
we know because they were humans that
they saw color like we do
we don't know if they made colors like
we do i mentioned the color white a
second ago
people actually argue about whether
white is a color or not an achromatic
something without color one eminent
color scientist called it this though
the mother of all
hues to some extent the history of the
way human beings have interacted with
color has been
a steady or punctuated progress of
having more and more pigments
and more and more ways of making things
have colors
but throughout all that time one of the
most steadfast principles you have to
have
something to make white something to be
a substrate that you can put other
colors against
something that when you mix it can
either make those colored things
lighter or give them more opacity or
make them brighter
so that essentially has been having to
have a white pigment
it's white is one of the bases of the
axis that you can measure
um colors and brightness by it's been
omnipresent
in coloring roman buildings in the same
era that it was making ceramic and the
tang dynasty was also
became the basis for makeup that women
there would wear all the way up through
those famous pictures of queen elizabeth
with the sort of white cake
on her face that was all white people
really vibe on white stuff though
calcium carbonates include things like
lime and also kaolin which is the
mineral that makes ceramics and fine
porcelain possible
people try to make white pigments out of
all kinds of stuff in fact partially
that's because you need it to mix with
other pigments to
lighten them and brighten them and make
them more opaque but white's actually
tricky because
where most pigments as i said absorb
some wavelengths and reflect others
white has to reflect pretty much all of
them but not
back the way they came because that
would be a mirror basically why it is
organized disorganization
refracts every wavelength every which
way for something to be white the
particles inside it have to scatter all
wavelengths equally and efficiently
water droplets suspended in air are very
good at this that's clouds protein and
fat suspended in water is very good at
this that's
milk for most of human history though
the big white was this lead white
it was a component of makeup it was a
component of house paints was a thing
that artists use
of course lead white was also scary
because it was hugely toxic and everyone
knew they knew since ancient rome how
toxic this stuff was
so much so because there was so much use
of it in the 19th century for industrial
uses and for paint because everybody
wanted their world to have nice colors
that the hazards of it had been become
the incentive to invent the entire field
of occupational safety
it was a mess which means the world was
open to a replacement
in the late 1800s an engineer named
august rossi
came from italy to new york and he made
kind of a business out of understanding
titaniferous ores
especially because people were trying to
mine iron out of the adirondacks
and make steel and that was like 25
titanius so at that point most people
thought that the way you would make good
steel out of something like that was to
take the titanium out
but in 1908 rossi noticed that the
chemical process he was using to purify
titanium produced as one of its
intermediate steps a fine brilliant
white powder
he mixed it with salad oil and famously
brushed it across a piece of paper
this was a big moment rossi knew about
the dangers of lead
and he understood the hegemony of
national lead conglomerate that was
selling the stuff in paint
so he and his partner added a new
business line titanium dioxide pigment
that's the basis for all kinds of paints
and coatings it has a huge refractive
index
it's opaque and it's bright you find it
even coatings and paints of other colors
it's
the main ingredient in a lot of those
paints you also find it in coatings of
pills
some kinds of paper almost every
cosmetic in your medicine cabinet
sometimes in the white sugar powder on
supermarket powdered donuts because it's
relatively inert
used to be an oreo filling it's a
multi-billion dollar industry
internationally
drives a huge amount of business the
bright colors of modern art of the
industrial age
of streamlined modern that's this this
stuff and it's
really it's everywhere even today
sprinkles and
sudafed and toothpaste this was all part
of
what one historian has called a
chromatic revolution
in order to make products seem new and
modern they
took on new colors and that started a
kind of um
interrelationship a dynamic where new
technologies would create new colors and
those new colors would inspire people to
create new technologies back and forth
even though there's some kind of crass
capitalism involved there
the the transition
in a you know really weird but i think
real way of uh of dorothy walking from
kansas into
oz of a world that goes from being
not black and white or sepia tone
because of course that's just the way
people now will think about it because
we're influenced by the way the movies
looked
but but colors that were more likely to
fade and that were more likely to be
earth tones
into something vivid and vibrant that we
think of as the
as the 20th century and now the 21st it
was titanium dioxide
really that was one of the things that
made that possible what
didn't exactly change though and what's
still kind of unclear is how we talk
about those colors this is changing
direction a little bit but
i want to ask you another question do
you see the color blue in this painting
this is the painting athena appearing to
odysseus to reveal the island of ithaca
by giuseppe buttani it's a depiction of
a scene from homer's odyssey
those stories or rather one specific
read of those stories sparked a
tremendous controversy
that an increasingly colorful world only
made worse does everyone see the same
colors if they don't have names for them
or
read that differently what do you call
the colors between the ones you know the
names of
and what does that say about you and
your culture and about how the brain
works because
color is a really good way to understand
linguistics which makes it a really good
way to try to understand cognition
in 1858 10 years before this guy became
prime minister of england
he wrote a book called studies on homer
in the homeric age he pointed out that
homer never used a word that meant blue
or green
in the original sure the sea might be
wine dark
and dawn might be rosy fingered but like
what does that even mean
gladstone had a hypothesis the ancient
greeks
he said didn't see color like we do they
didn't say blue because they couldn't
see blue
that's nonsense of course they were
humans they had human eyeballs and
brains they
didn't lack the blue photoreceptor or
have different eyes that function
differently than ours
and you know maybe the ocean wasn't blue
maybe it was green or
black but most translators today agree
that the greeks were using color words
just differently those were colors that
meant something to them that had what
scientists call salience you remember
those color orders that i showed you
plato's version of that went from white
to black and one of the primaries that
he used
was translated roughly to like sparkling
or brilliant that was a
specular illumination that specular look
was something that they valued
so that may be what the wine dark sea
was all about
um still though you know the idea that
some people you know
other kinds of people didn't see color
as well as like nominally civilized
colonialists did that was a pretty
sticky
idea so grant allen thought that he
would test it out
uh alan was actually one of the
inventors of both science fiction and
detective fiction
but alan tried a cool experiment he sent
letters to as he said missionaries
government officials and other persons
working among the most uncivilized races
not above a bit of casual racism was our
grant
he sent those all over the world asking
those people to ask the locals a bunch
of questions and the answer at the end
basically was yeah they all see the same
colors they don't all have the same
names and sometimes they don't have
some names for colors at all but if you
teach people the name in a different
language they pick that right up
people were seeing the same colors they
just didn't call them the same thing it
had
something more to do with culture than
with biology this was all anecdotal of
course what all this
eventually led up to in the 20th century
was a
mutation idea into what's now called
linguistic relativism sometimes this is
called the superior warf hypothesis
after a harvard linguist named edward
sapir and an autodidactic fire
investigator
self-taught linguist named benjamin
wharf and the most simplistic version of
the idea
even defining this is controversial but
just work with me is that
the things that you have words for in
your head are a limit on what you can
actually think of and about
language is thought like i said color is
a very good tool for thinking about
language so you can test this or you can
try
in the 1960s two linguists brent berlin
and paul k had noticed in their field
work
that some languages had fewer basic
color words things like yellow and green
like i asked you to imagine up at the
top
that didn't mean anything other than a
color than other languages did some
languages had fewer than others
why they decided to do a more rigorous
version
of what allen had tried to do with his
letters what berlin and kay tried to do
was ask people basically which colors
are which what they're called which ones
are subcategories
what names do you have and so on and the
crazy thing is
they found a pattern they found that all
languages
develop color terms in a specific order
they said
first they start with white and black
then they'll include a red
then you get either a green or a yellow
then you get both then you get blue
and so on it turned out to be pretty
wrong
under fire for potentially some racial
assumptions and also because they
talk to people who are bilingual so the
languages will be overlapping and a
bunch of other things
they tried it again they went big they
went not to bilingual speakers in the
california bay area but to informants
around the world dozens of different
languages and places
and they found that what was going on
was much more complicated and mannered
that languages tended to separate their
color spaces into light colors and dark
colors and then develop more words as
needed
from there what we're talking about here
is something called categorical
perceptions the ability to distinguish
among stuff
and name that stuff so having words for
things really does matter
this is just a small example but russian
speakers have two basic color terms for
blue
they have a light blue and a dark blue i
won't try to pronounce those because my
russians
i don't have any russian um so whereas
we just have blue they have two
if you show people uh
those colors and then one of the other
ones so a triangle test two of one color
one of the others
russian speakers are faster at telling
you whether the third one is the same or
different than the others
than english speakers are the hypothesis
there being the idea being that if you
have the words for it
then you can see it more quickly you can
think about it more quickly
what you'd really like though if you
wanted to try to separate cultural and
linguistic influences on color
perception from like innate biological
categorical perception of color
you would want something that could see
like a human but didn't have language
so i recommend one of these uh this one
is mine
from many many years ago so and you
can't have that specific one but
something like this
and seriously no for real this works you
do what anna franklin at the university
of sussex did you strap some four months
olds
into car seats and make them look at
colors because babies
if they see something unfamiliar they
look at it for longer it's kind of a
basic tool in
developmental psychology and you can
tell what categories they distinguish
between
and which ones they don't if something
they haven't seen before they look at it
longer if they've seen it before it's
already in a category then they're
looking for shorter
anna franklin tried this and found at
the end basically the babies see
red green blue yellow and purple
before language these are the categories
of color
but what are the categories for what do
they mean
in 2017 a couple of researchers ted
gibson who's an information theorist at
mit
and bevel conway who's a color vision
researcher at the nih and
sort of my grew in all of this they
tried the same kind of show the colors
came with speakers
um that the berlin and k folks had tried
with native speakers of english
spanish and chimane which is an
indigenous language in south america
this shows which modal terms or basic
color words the speakers of each
language used for mansell chips it shows
that shimano had fewer words
fewer speakers had modal terms for those
colors than spanish or english did
but then they tried something new they
played a sort of guessing game
they would take the color chips and try
to see how long it took people
in each language to describe a given
ship to explain which one they meant
to a person they were talking to and the
idea was that if you had
fewer words to do this if it took less
time to do it that meant that the color
was somehow more information efficient
in the language that you were speaking
so these are from the top to bottom
different languages english at the top
then spanish speakers then chima knight
speakers
and right to left information efficiency
it doesn't really matter which specific
colors do which
because you can see what the overall
divide is there you can see that there's
a division between
what someone who's an artist like conway
is would call warm colors
and cool colors so there's roughly the
same difficulty conveying the idea of
the same colors but in both colors in
the warm
longer wavelengths are the ones that uh
that are more efficient why are they
more salient
you can tell as many evolutionary just
sell stories about that as you want but
this is sort of clear proof that at
least they are
somehow okay so what's next that's how
we make colors and think about colors
now a little bit
but because of that relationship between
technologies for making colors and
thinking about them
this is all changing a couple years ago
i went to a lab at mit
researchers named yang she and michael
foche they work with a 3d printer to try
to
basically forage paintings not for
criminal reasons but
what they're trying to do is print
paintings
that look indistinguishable from the
originals no matter what color light you
look at them under now that's a big deal
the way the iron brain remap the colors
that we're seeing to account for the
color of the surface the thing that
we're looking at but also the color of
the
ambient illumination is a vast mystery
nobody really knows how the brain does
it and what they wanted to do
was create a printout essentially of an
image
that would look the same under the same
kinds of different lights as the
original
so to do it they kind of reached back
into the past they took a process called
half toning putting little dots of color
next to each other to make color
printing that's how color printing works
familiar if you're a fan of comic books
or
magazines or neo-impressionism but
instead of limiting themselves to cyan
magenta yellow and black the classic
colors of magazine publishing
they added a bunch a bunch of pigments
red green blue violet orange
even a titanium white of course they
used a machine learning algorithm
and told it to look at colors that it
saw in the world and figure out how they
changed in our different illumination
and then come up with print the same
colors that the originals
they were able to pull it off almost
completely that's an original on top and
then the copies are below basically
every scanned pixel of the original
gets a a three-dimensional um like
hyperspectral reflectance map
that the computer then recreates with
pigments and the 3d printer multiple
layers of 3d printer
now there's some kind of color physics
going on there that figures out how
light interacts with surfaces
but nobody knows what that physics is
she and foshee don't know they left
the machine algorithm so they don't know
how it works either the computer is able
to make
fake colors that nobody else knows how
to make somehow and
nobody has yet asked the computer one of
the things that the color
scientists that i talked to were most
excited about
were the possibilities less of like high
resolution screens and more of wider
gamuts
so the color gamut is what colors are
able to be shown by a screen
and the idea isn't that you'd be able to
show colors that people
can't see but to capture more colors
that they do see out in the world so
right now if you have a
a screen with a too narrow a gamut and
you try to show a sunset
let's say you won't it'll it'll it'll
like cover up the colors that it can't
depict so everything will just look like
the same yellow instead of a bunch of
yellows and golds let's say
so a color gamut a wider color gamut is
part of what
new and oncoming standards in
high definition tvs and digital
televisions will have
but they were actually more excited
about high dynamic range
dynamic range is a different axis in
color space it's the light to dark
axis not the not the colors the actual
hues
and if you can increase that axis if you
can make the dark super dark and the
bright
super bright you can show more colors
you can expand the gamut
but also some people think that you can
even get more um like emotional
range there's a researcher at dolby who
studies neuroscience as well as how to
make better screens
and she says that if you have really
really super high dynamic range and you
like
look at fire for example that your your
skin will respond as if you're seeing
heat
um pixar animators use uh the
six primary color laser projectors of
dolby high definition
digital cinema and the ultra high
dynamic range ramp from
bright bright white to black black black
and they're doing experiments with
inducing after images
using really bright colors to induce the
after image that's the complement of a
color
so that you'll see colors that aren't
really there
uh more colors and color things are
still coming
every time people learn new color
science they used to make new color
technology
like these are all samples for possible
paints for cars
um and uh the way you do this is um
you include in the paint mica little
flakes like corn flakes
and they reflect light in different
directions and different amounts of
light in different ways so you get the
sort of
when you move around the car it's red
over here and green over there
um but mica actually um comes with a lot
of impurities
so they're they're trying to use
artificial
synthetic mica maybe vantablack
nanoscale nanostructure black that's the
blackest black ever known
um or maybe what you see here this is uh
work from the researchers jingu park
and ben rogers at harvard these are
structural colors they're not made from
traditional pigments at all they're
they're nanoscale structures
tuned beads of styrofoam actually that
reflect light mechanistically rather
than chemically
i don't know if you're if you're an
entomology fan but a lot of beetles have
really extraordinary
carapaces they're the armor that they
have someone that's really specular it
looks like metal
glowing um and there's one called the
cyphoculus i'm probably pronouncing that
wrong
that's ultra bright white uh brighter
even than titanium dioxide is and it
does that
um not because there's any white pigment
in it because the the way that
the nanoscale the way its armor is
structured and after that
i don't know because of course no color
is impossible
there's no missing shade of blue even if
the ones that we can see
are limited by our own biology and our
own neurology the colors that we can
make
are probably not thank you
thank you so much adam that was
fantastic and i'm really glad that
you're able to join me here at the
interval in san francisco for some live
questions
welcome thank you i'm always happy to be
at the interval it's nice to be back
excellent well um this is a fantastic
talk and i love how kind of
first principle it is and it makes you
question everything you kind of know
about
you know the way you perceive the world
and i'd love to hear a little bit more
about the human tetrachromats
and you know i think we've talked a
little bit about this and you know are
they you know are they the super tasters
of color do they get more than
than i do um i mean maybe m1 i don't
even know i don't know how to test for
it but the
uh you know are they and then i also
there's also the colorblind humans and
they they kind of have other
types of you know high contrast
superpowers um
what is the where do these fit in why do
they do do we evolutionary understand
why we have these
people it's great that you use the
analogy of a super taster
because that really does try to get at
the
the problem the question that we're
asking is a is about
trying to attach metaphoric meaning to
to these words right so
um the equivalency that one might draw
if
if a person had an extra photoreceptor a
fourth kind making it making that person
a tetrachromat
or putting them in some way like birds
you know have those four photoceptors or
the mantis shrimp with the twelve
would they see more
colors like see colors out at the edges
or
they see are they distinguishing more
finely
among the colors that they that we
already see
so where you and i would see the same
blue
uh this our our hypothetical and nominal
tetrachromat would see two different
ones we'd say oh obviously those are two
different colors
um and so that you know those those
people do seem to exist our own ability
even as as trichromats humans that were
like weird among the primates even the
primates don't really do that and the
evolutionary substory there that
you would tell would be to say well if
you're um
if you're a predator hunting especially
during the
day like the big giant reptiles were
like you know dinosaurs and stuff then
it's really good to have really high
high grade high definition color vision
and you see that even today in their
descendants in the birds right and like
raptors having really good vision that
way that's
finely grained and good colors whereas
you're descended as we are from the
little nocturnal furry things that we're
screwing around between their legs at
night trying to stay out of their way
and maybe find some bugs you don't
actually need color vision because you
don't really have a lot of colors to see
at night
it's good to have night vision so you
see that in other
some of our fellow mammals but
but it's only a mutation in one of those
receptors
that kind of doubles up makes a new
receptor that has a slightly different
peak uh sensitivity that the spectrum
that it sees or slightly
you know moved over along that along the
sliding scale
what we call the visible spectrum that
then humans and
primates that we're descended from
recapitulate the trichromatic color
vision
there are researchers who um who are
working on using genetic
techniques to give primates that don't
have all three
photoreceptors as we do a third one
to see if they then see colors the way
human beings do and there's some there's
some indication that they might that
work has been going on for a long time
colorblindness that human beings with
non-standard color vision were actually
one of the beginning touch points for
how scientists figured out how color
vision worked at all
the uh the the chemist john dalton who
invented the idea of the adam dalton was
himself colorblind and he he
was from manchester which when he was
growing up uh
was becoming the center of textiles as
part of the industrial revolution part
of textile work was having a lot of
different dyes and pigments to make
these types of different colors
so he started collecting different bits
of thread and stuff and saying what
color he saw
when he looked at it and finally wrote
about that
and had his eye donated his eyes to the
local museum to see if there was if they
could look through it and see if
colors look different if you looked
through the back of dalton's eyes wow
there's still
we're still at this museum you can go
and check them out you can say like i'd
like to see dalton's eyes please
um you can't see it um
but it wasn't it was work like that
there was some theoretical idea that
um that you could take what what newton
had described with this range of colors
and even you know his basic color terms
his primaries are sort of arbitrary as
well he was trying to match to the
alchemical and platonic octave and so he
named all these colors certain things
but like
if i look at a rainbow or spectrum i
don't actually see those as well as
newton said that he did but people were
trying to figure out well how does one
color get to another how do they mix how
do light how do
the colors of light mix into another
color forming metamers
how do pigments mix and sometimes they
make new colors sometimes they just get
darker these are all sort of mysterious
things scientifically
um so thomas young
figured out that because he was
interested in oscillation wavelengths of
sound figured out that there was some
overlap of what newton had been talking
about
in 1801 i think gives this braver a
series of lectures over the course of a
few weeks saying like actually all you
really need
to see all of this range of colors is
you really just need three
receptors any column receptors but you
just need three elements
in the eye that you can combine in
different ways and you'll be able to see
if you have more of one and less of the
other two or more of two and less of one
then you'll be able to see this whole
range of wavelengths that he had done
frequency calculations for that really
matched newton's
calculations pretty well um he died
pretty early
he was a savant scientist and actually
went on and helped translate the rosetta
stone in fact
um but it was uh james clark maxwell
then who comes in and gets really
interested in the same work
all these cooks have been training using
things like spinning tops and mixing
pieces of paper like origami folds so
that they could mix and amounts of
colors and
see how they mix together and see what
color somebody would see and say like oh
well if you have 30
more blue this is what color people
perceive again all
working with people who were color-blind
who did have color vision it was
different than
most human beings do to try to figure
out well what what's the difference and
does it help
prove our point here what maxwell
finally did this is a great experiment
he had a device that could shine
a different colored light into people's
eyes
and tune it a little bit like like the
experiment that i was describing that
i've you know tried
when i said try to imagine what your
favorite yellow is what the best yellow
is he could do that with different
colors and
and use it to create a triangular color
space where he would put
red green blue at the vertices of a
triangle and then
the way they mixed together would be
along the sides and then the way all
three colors mixed together would be how
you colored the inside of the
triangle and did this experiment where
he showed people a specific color
people who had some form of
colorblindness he didn't know there were
a bunch of different forms of
colorblindness at the time you
would show people a certain color and
then he would show them other colors and
ask them
what they saw what color they saw versus
what
color it really was and it eventually
saw that you could
you could plot those and they would make
a line you could draw a line through
them to one corner
triangle he realized like oh that's the
receptor that those people are missing
or that's not functioning in these
people's eyes that one receptor and
you realize not only did that show kind
of how colorblind this worked
but also that it proved that
trichromatic theory that
most people that almost all people had
those three receptors that could do the
work
through this very complicated neural
calculation turned out to be much more
complicated than anybody expected
this with just those three that you can
make all the other colors and that's
intuitive to us now because
people are watching this on a screen are
seeing a screen where all of the colors
the
fast range if you're looking at a uhd
screen vast gamut of color
almost all the colors of the human eye
can perceive um are really just being
produced by
three different colors of leds and then
sometimes a white one too
[Music]
cool and we're going to bring in one of
the founders of lung now uh kevin kelly
shortly um
the after this question the you showed
you know a lot of history of color
wheels and kind of that that
you know that this science is littered
by the bodies of people who tried to
create the ultimate color wheel but
how how far do color wheels go back what
is the oldest one that we know
well so um a lot of theorists you know
as backstars plato certainly tried to
come up with an order
putting a color in order the oldest one
there's a wonderful book called color
ordered
by a researcher named ralph kwame cooney
i may be pronouncing his name i
apologize
um and the oldest one that he identified
is actually a
circle of um of vials of liquid
that are different that are either from
clear through yellow to dark brown
and what they are a different color or
urine they use
doctors using this color wheel to
identify like well how sick is this
person that's really dark brownie
that's right our friend is pretty sick
um
and uh the thing i like about that the
most is that you had to um
to make it work you have to have uh
um these glass vials you know around
basically
what we call a boiling flask now in the
lab like the same kind of thing that's
hanging up here at the interval with a
lot of the people's personal bottles
and those are the same kind of vials
that enabled
arab scientists in the abbasid period to
start to figure out how spectrum and how
spectrum rainbows work so before
newton that they were able to use to
watch how light reflected through those
before they had prisms
to try to figure out that oh different
you know that light maybe refracts
differently depending on what wave like
we don't know the wavelength is but
there's different kinds of light that
refract differently and maybe that's how
rainbows work there was the it was that
kind of work that led up to what newton
was finally able to do in 1600s
oh very cool um all right well welcome
on uh kevin kelly who
uh was the founding editor uh wired as
well as one of the founders of long now
um and we're at wired where you work
welcome kevin kelly
that's great to be here adam i love your
book
and your talk it's really great to have
something that we
take for granted kind of exploded and
revealed to be as
amazing as it is once we examine it
and you've done a great job in
explaining that there was a couple of um
questions from listeners one jim jenkins
from youtube says is there a simple way
to tell if
a human is a tetrachromatic
super you know i mean like is there a
test to tell well
whether you have this uh fourth kind of
cone how do they test it that's a really
good question
you know i wonder if they're
see the problem is there's so much
individual variation already so that if
you went and got like the whole range of
muncell blues and put them down in front
of you and me we'd probably there are
probably some
that i think i'm just diagrammatic that
probably like i wouldn't see a
difference than you would too so it's
hard to do that kind of test without
doing
sort of the straight ahead genotyping
there must be a test but
i i feel done without this not knowing
this but there must be a test that you
like you should be able to go and get
isn't one of the home genome test test
actually called color you would think
maybe they would
but there must be some people who have
maybe
a more refined ability to discern
colors uh that we couldn't
an ordinary person might not notice the
difference between um
for sure and this is this is actually
one of the places where the color book
overlaps with the booze book
um because one of the things that uh
research into people who are master
somalia is so people who are very good
at
identifying wines where they're from and
how they taste and all these fine grain
variations
research into what somalians are able to
do often says
that they they don't actually um have a
better sense of taste or smell then
what i might have is an untrained sort
of just person who likes wine um
but they have a lot more words to
describe the things that they are
smelling and tasting
and they can use those to apply to what
they're doing and then that gives them a
greater range of
greater descriptive range which is great
it's one of the reasons why
when you go wine tasting it's probably a
good idea to not get the tasting words
first
before you taste something get the tasty
notes after because it's really easy to
incept people with those tasting notes
right you can say like you're going to
taste the blackberry in this and
suddenly it tastes like
okay so that's true somalia i i think
that's also true in
brilliant artists or in people who were
textile designers
or people who are doing mosaic work that
they may have a much
they'll have a greater sensitivity to
their possible range and have more words
to describe them and that gives them or
more access
more access to being able to see these
are different colors that i can describe
so
it's it is possible that i might be able
to see like yeah i guess those two blues
are different but
that's just blue i don't have a kind of
a way to say that they're different or
they're so close that i don't even
notice that they're different until
someone comes around and says like
actually that one's a little bit more
gray and then i go oh
right of course it is i didn't i didn't
have access to it and that's why the
linguistics and cognitive research into
color is so interesting because it can
kind of
at least begin to reveal and get it so
you spent uh a long time working on this
book has
um doing the research did it change how
you
saw the world or how you saw color
personally did it
um impact you and change your mind from
even when you first started writing it
by a lot
um i actually had uh
i had a little i had a little bit of um
dorm room like existential crisis for a
while where
after talking to enough researchers
especially um especially after doing
research on the on the dress that
whether you know whether
solid blue or white and you talk to
enough of those folks and
and they'll you get to the end of these
interviews and you kind of go yeah but
it was blue though
and they sort of go look it's it's it's
charming
that you think there's any such thing as
an objective color but there really
isn't it's just surfaces in the way they
interact with you know with the quantum
nature of the universe
and after hearing that enough times you
start to walk around looking around like
oh man none of it's real like it's all
just a surface
with photons bouncing off of it um which
i
finally like that'll keep you up at
night i mean i was starting to like
really sort of get a little nervous
about that
no it's like you gotta just own the fact
that you're that our think meat makes a
world for us and we live in it and
that's okay
um it's not just i'm not i didn't i
didn't degrade into
horrible solipsism my um
my partner at home is a weaver we have a
lot of looms
and a lot of fiber and a lot of textile
um in our house
and i have a vastly greater appreciation
for the
for that work especially because
and there are a lot of ways that um uh
that weaving and textiles
prefigure a lot of the kind of math um
that computer scientists do now but one
of them is that when you're
when you overlap fibers and this is i
only know this because i would come home
and say did you know and she would look
at me and go yeah
yeah that's what i'm doing with the
thing that i know that um
that you're not actually mixing the
you're not mixing the pigments you're
not mixing the colors
they're sitting next to each other and
when colors sit adjacent to each other
they have all kinds of weird effects in
your eye your brain they assume some of
the properties the complement of the
color
and and and with weaving specifically
they begin to act very much like pixels
um because you make smaller and smaller
dots as the depending on the overlap and
you can make patterns
with those pixels they don't use that
terminology but a lot of the
um the early design that computer
scientists had to figure out to make
pixels work on screens like
anti-aliasing
that early max used to do to make to
make
text look curved when they didn't have
the resolution to curve it those are
things that the weavers discovered a
long time
previous to that that they had to do
with the colors they were working with
so now they're
the the the dynamic in my house of like
what sort of color work is happening on
a loom at any given time versus
what i know about it and what she knows
about it has uh
it's it's it's changed our hobbies for
the for the better
well it actually makes a little loop
back to the jacquard loom
and the beginning of programming and
there's the pixel
so um thanks for that um a little
closing the loop
um great book thanks for the great talk
i appreciate it please
thank you thanks kevin you know one of
the reasons
i'm trying to let you know why you know
you showed some of the archaea that have
in some way color perception um and then
you know humans have clearly have color
perception
but you know as we you know talked about
with the world war ii bombers they're
kind of
they were some of those were better at
actually
doing their job if they saw less color
um
but you know do we do humans have all
this color perception for danger of ones
is it for hunting do we know where that
you know is it so you don't eat the red
berry or the red
apple as it were um right i mean
one of the um one of the ways that
caller scientists amuse each other
uh after a long after in the bar at a
conference
is to go through the different
evolutionary stories but what's it for
though why is it
why is it there it has to convey an
evolutionary advantage it has to convey
a reproductive
advantage or a sort of sexual selective
advantage and in fact this was you know
the color of the morpho butterflies
it was the thing that darwin and wallace
argued about was was specifically they
were talking about why do these things
have color it doesn't convey an
advantage in fact it may
it may confer a disadvantage there's
some research on um
on guppies in mountain streams
in south america and this is sort of
famous animal coloration research
where the guppies will have different
color they're the same species of guppy
but as you move down
the stream when there are shrimp that
will leak the guppy they have different
colors
that either more appealing to a guppy
potential guppy mate
or less appealing or like less visible
to the shrimp that are trying to eat the
guppy
and there's this balance and so what you
really want for the guppy is to have
colors that show up in the wavelengths
that the guppies see
but not in the ones that the shrimp sees
right
so some of the you know some of the good
theories are the colors we see colors
because it's
you know for sex like all kinds of other
stuff that we do that doesn't seem to
have any other purpose
um because it's you know that's
important um
but uh but yeah there's a possibility
that it's because we're trying to find
fruit
in the in the forest fructivore
hypothesis you want to see the red fruit
against the green trees
it doesn't really make that much sense
because there's a lot of green fruit and
like
a lot of our primate ancestors eat the
green things so how does that help
you you really want to be able to see
shape there's a hypothesis that it's a
way to
be able to better perceive uh emotional
state
there are certainly primates that when
they're
when they're at the peak of their
fertility then parts of their body will
change color
when we we unconsciously convey
emotional state by changing color of our
skin if we have
if we have a skinny color that you can
see that not everybody does the range of
human skin color is actually not that
wide it sort of goes from
you know pink to brown with a little bit
of red shade in it but within that
there's a lot of dark light variation
um but still you can imagine like being
able to see if someone was blushing
would convey
confirm some evolutionary advantage
potentially
these horror stories are really they're
they're hard to tell and they're hard to
listen to because there's no real way to
go back
and unpack the the truth of them
um as you say it clearly has some value
it has an informational value
um the the um
but people who see a different human
beings who see a different range of
colors
have other abilities as well this is
part of the long time
it's one of the arcs in the book is this
the long-term war between form and color
since at least the um since at least the
greeks a conversation about this
mostly false dichotomy between whether
form was more important the shape of
things
which you really see by light and dark
really that's what we really mean unless
you're feeling them
um or the color of things and and that
really um
came to a peak with sort of the art
criticism of the late 19th century where
there were people who were arguing
people arguing that um color was more
feminine and therefore
less somehow less like a nonsense you
know completely culturally
colored with a lowercase c argument
right um
but until uh really until the
renaissance if you had a statue
it was probably painted if you wasn't
painted
then you didn't that's your show you
didn't have enough money to get a proper
statue essentially
and it wasn't until like michelangelo
and leonardo da vinci both essentially
said actually
we want to see any color on this stuff
it's just the form that's the pure
that's the purest thing but that
conversation is a truth and beauty
argument it's not a it's not an
informational or
reproductive or evolutionary value it's
you you don't have beauty without truth
or truth to that beauty the form and
color on your two sides of the same
thing
right and we're getting close to the end
here um but
one of the things that's interesting to
me is you talked a little bit about the
pixar thing of how
you know they're actually in a way using
a i guess you'd call it like a psycho
chromatic effect
to create a new color right and um but
you know
is the electrification of have we has it
been studied as
electrification of societies and um
emissive technologies like televisions
um and computer screens and now cell
phones
is that changing at all the way we see
color do we know is it
is it is that affecting us there's a
um there's a pretty good case
to be made and some people did study
this for example in the case of the
dress
i go back to this because i covered it
because it was a big deal because it
really changed a lot of color science
too
um that the fact that that happened
meant that there were certain years of
research that followed trying to figure
out what's the internet name of the
dress
yes and there's so there's a case to be
made there that one of the reasons that
one of the reasons that that image
created a
rigidly bimodal color illusion right one
where you like once you saw it one way
you didn't
switch whereas with like illusions of
form the the is it a
woman or a duck or a rabbit or a duck or
is the cube forward or back those kind
of illusions
they're bi-modal but but when humans
look at them we tend to
we tend to switch back and forth right
and
one of the weird things about the the
dress meme was that once you
once your brain decided which color
you stuck with it you couldn't you sort
of couldn't see the other one
after you're looking for a while you
can't i've started to be able to anyway
that's another one of those things where
i got totally messed up when i look at
it now
but sorry i looped a long way away here
but the point i was trying to make
was that there's a case that one of the
reasons that happened was not just the
nature of that color but that people
were seeing it on emissive screens
you know everybody saw it on their
phones or on their you know on their
screen at work nobody saw the the
reflective image the picture
there wasn't one it was a picture taken
with someone's phone
so clearly that had something to do with
it right
would it have happened with the actual
dress at a party
right uh and and the answer that's
almost certainly no
um and part of the reason why is that if
you were seeing well
actually i might i might reverse myself
on that but if you were seeing that
dress in real life
then when the thing happened that
probably happened with that image which
is
the person walked through a shadow
they would then walk out of that shadow
and your brain would correct
your brain would do the calculation and
go oh no no that wasn't that it was this
it's this
i'm looking at it now and i can see it
in different circumstances and i can
subtract the illuminance the
illuminance from the object i can do all
the work of color constancy that i need
to do
um but in fact some of the research on
the actual dress
there's a researcher in england who got
who bought it
and and put it in a gallery room and
then illuminated it with led lights
red green blue leds so that you can
adjust how much of each of those
lights you're shining on it but it still
looks like normal still looks like
normal light so
if you and i walk in the room it seems
like it's being lit by white light but
in fact it's actually sneakily not white
light it's some
adjustment of colors for the leds and
they were able to make people see that
dress any color they wanted
oh wow and in fact it works on art too
like even art that you recognize you can
make any art
do the cathedral ruin you know money's
cathedral arena can look like you know
all any time of day
that's the sort of thing where you start
to go like oh maybe there's not a
it becomes the province of the
philosophers whether that object has a
color
that surface has a color or whether that
color is created in a dialogue with our
eyes and our brains and our
cultural experience right i've certainly
heard you know when people talk about
you know paintings
that were created before electrical play
that
you know if you're looking at them in
anything other than sunlight or
candlelight
you kind of aren't seeing them the way
the artist intended um
that's an interesting question one of
our other questions is you know when
humans
colonize other planets orbiting other
stars you know how will the local sun's
unique
uh light spectrum affect their
perception so
you know it's kind of all the time right
so one of my favorite things
yes trying to figure out in fact there
are researchers who study exoplanets who
both use the color that reflects off of
those planets to try to understand their
atmospheres because different
atmospheres will show different colors
as we look at those exoplanets even the
little tiny specks of exoplanet that we
can see
but also yes trying to figure out okay
well there are
these are planets that have a different
have an atmosphere with a different
composition than ours
so that changes what kind of light gets
through they have a sun
that's different than ours um so it's
emitting a different spectrum
than ours is let's say there are plants
what color are the leaves what what's
that version of chlorophyll what's that
version of the pigments that are doing
photosynthesis
are they absorbing all of the light they
can so they would look black to us and
in fact if
it was a human standing there versus
some whatever primate thing whatever
lemur-like thing that evolved on that
world would have eyes that evolved under
that sun
in that atmosphere and would see those
colors in a very different way they
would have a different range of visible
spectrum
in the same way that on earth a bee or a
fish or a snake has a different visible
spectrum that a human being does
and you have to take all that stuff into
account they take it into account on the
on
the cameras on the rovers that are on
mars right now perseverance has cameras
on mars
that are designed to take into account
both what
what the image that they see would look
like to a human standing there
would look like if it was illuminated by
earth light what looked like what
it would look like if it's illuminated
by mars light and
this sort of metaphor because they don't
the researchers don't think about it
this way but they'll say this would
be what it would look like to a martian
right
interesting yeah it reminds me of that
one day that we had
kind of ominously last year in the bay
area when the fires were so bad that the
sun
basically didn't come up and everything
was orange and
the kind of hilarious part of that was
that when people used their iphones to
take pictures the iphones
color corrected all the orange away so
the only way to take a picture of it was
with like earlier
you know you know non non-software
corrected things
then if the iphone couldn't take a
picture of it it obviously didn't happen
exactly just like all my meals
the uh all right well i want to wrap up
you know thank you so much for this but
that um
the last question i want to ask you the
last time you were here amir
seven years ago was uh with proof and
now
with this and yeah what is the next
first principle based project that
you're going to teach us about
we're in my booking space for 2028 yeah
we're filling up i know it took me a
long time to write xander
that's not what i'm saying this is long
now it was short yeah you know i think i
just wanted to
are you working on a new project yeah i
i have i have some notions
yeah right that's i know that's all i'm
trying to ask jesus man um
yeah i have some notions uh the that
that there was a
virginia pulse rule what a really good
book called the fabric of civilization
um that sort of uh
was like i was hoping there might be a
textile weaving thing there and i think
she wrote it
so maybe that's not gonna happen now um
i've gotten really i spent the last year
covering
for wired covering kovid19 and the thing
that i've gotten really interested in
there is
is sort of how to understand how science
works and how science does and what
science is supposed to do because so
much of what has happened
um with this tragedy this pandemic for
the last year has i think come down to
not being able to explain
what what we know how we know it how
scientists know it how
what scientists don't know and then how
to how to say that to people who who
don't have the same
scientific background knowledge um and
the very basic philosophy
of how trials work and how science works
and how scientists come to know things
has gotten i've been really compelled
i've written a few things about that and
i
i think maybe there's something there
too i you know
i don't know i've been staring at a
screen every weekend for a while i might
um
just go look at some colors outside in
the garden for a while right
please too well thank you so much and i
can't wait to
uh have a drink with you here at the
interval after this is uh
after this q a is done it's been a very
long time uh thank you so much for
joining us
thank you for having me it is it's a
pleasure and i'm i'm i'm glad to be back
and i want to thank you our audience
with long now and our members and our
sponsors of this series and looking
forward to having you at our next stop
thank you so much
[Music]